before we go on this possible indigenous
people's day
there's one thing you can do i didn't
even know it was columbus day a holiday
allegedly
here's one thing you can do today to
live a happier healthy and more
productive life
it's part of our partnership with
gretchen rubin and her award-winning
podcast it's called happier
according to a global survey more than
40 percent of adults say they are
impatient to get back to normal life
amid the pandemic i get it new york
times best-selling author gretchen rubin
joins us now to talk about how we can
incorporate more patients
into our everyday lives gretchen rubin
always good to see you but i think
you're asking a lot of people these days
to be patient it's very difficult to do
it is it is we're impatient with the
situation we want things to get back to
more or less normal we want to know when
we can travel
we're impatient with the people around
us because you know maybe parents and
children are sharing spaces or
you've got that co-worker who can't
figure out mute unmute and uh we're
impatient
i think i am that co-worker i can't
figure out
we've all been it we've all done it
we've all done it yeah you suggest
eliminating
obvious irritations which there seem to
be an extra large number of these days
how do we do that well look for the
things that are just
really jangling your nerves for a lot of
people outer order contributes to
intercom so maybe look for
you know festering messes that you can
get rid of
or maybe you have conflict with people
like someone keeps doing an important
zoom call while you're trying to fix
your snack in the kitchen
so work out expectations if you find
yourself
getting impatient how can you uh ease
those feelings
well one thing is to do a thoughtful
gesture warm gestures make warm feelings
so maybe bring the person a cup of
coffee
or do their chore for them remember to
be thankful for everything they're doing
remind yourself of what they're doing
that's helping you that drives out
feelings of impatience
and sometimes we just have to take a
deep breath bite our tongue and remember
we don't have to share every impatient
feeling that we have maybe make a joke
of it
sleep must be connected is it to being
impatient or patient
absolutely sleep i mean if we don't have
sleep we don't have
energy we don't have focus we lose our
sense of humor our sense of perspective
getting a good night's sleep i mean i'm
sure you all know more than ever
more than anyone getting that good
night's sleep and waking up well rested
really helps to be
stay patient i'm personally very
impressed we got tips on patients in two
minutes or less yes for the impatience
i'm still thinking about all the
festering messes in my apartment i don't
know i like that word festering
thinking we've all got them the mute
unmute button i actually had somebody
say
it's on the left hand side i know where
it is i just can't get to it
you're there gretchen thank you that'll
do it for us sometimes